[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's
Tuesday yep and we're talking about
another movie ding From Another World
the one that John Carpenter played uh uh
did his classic based his Classic on the
one that you know the thing
although I will say that it's like I
mean this movie and John Carpenter's
movie are based on a novel yeah
um and I'm going to say too that the
John Carpenter version is a lot more is
a lot closer to the source novel this
one is kind of but you can tell that
they didn't have the budget yeah to do
what the story you know kind of they
went straight 1950s monster movie it is
yeah there was no real Nuance in it the
whole idea of being absorbed by
something and being copied that was
that's not there it's just a vegetable
man because that was a lot cheaper
vegetable man yeah and it's like
vegetable Frankenstein super carrot they
call him in the movie and I know I'm not
making that up yeah
he's just a vegetable Frankenstein
although what's funny is that
this was one of my dad's favorite movies
when he was a kid this scared of John
Carpenter's favorite movies too and the
carpenter version came out he took me to
see it like three or four times up in
Mississippi
it scared the [ __ ] out of me we I love
that movie I was probably about what 14
and then 80 what what year was that that
one came out maybe 82 82 yeah yeah so I
was I don't know
maybe 13. I'm gonna kill yeah because
you're a couple years older than me yeah
and I was 10 in 1982. I didn't see in
the theater I saw like a couple years
later I saw it in the theater multiple
times my dad was like we're gonna see
that again tomorrow
I'm driving back from here driving back
I was I was [ __ ] spooked I was like
yeah yeah we're gonna see it tomorrow
yeah
I loved being scared yeah me too I did
too yeah we're gonna see it tomorrow
it's like ride a roller coaster yeah and
then you're worried like man a whole way
back I was like
thinking of everything from John
Carpenter's version those dudes being
absorbed it's like man what is something
like that's real what if it's out there
you know
yeah it's like I said we'd be [ __ ] if
that was what would I do alien yeah oh
yeah no if something like that showed up
that'd be it yep
well that's what we see it they even
knew that in the movie that's why
they're like we can't let it leave you
know what I mean because it'll like take
over the Earth Danny Rowling said there
needs to be a color version of this film
to buy now I'm not sure about nowadays I
was watching um the Cinemassacre
uh breakdown of this earlier and he had
a colorized version that was from the
90s I guess remember when Ted Turner was
colorizing all of those black and white
movies there was a colorized version of
thing from another world and he had a
VHS copy of it but I don't know if they
ever released the colorized version to
like you know um
I mean I like black and white movies so
I don't really
I don't usually like seek out colorized
versions I mean I'll watch them if
that's like all it's around I'm not like
you know opposed to it or anything like
that but it's like a lot of times I
would rather just watch it in its
original yeah it doesn't make a bit it
doesn't make a big difference no I don't
think it does and some of the
differences actually might work against
it like evidently them was supposed to
be color it was yeah uh but it but the
ants the way they were painted it didn't
it didn't look good they were almost
kind of glittery yeah it evidently
looked better in uh in black and black
and white yeah remember yeah because we
did a um we did a breakdown of that a
while back and I said yeah it was
initially supposed to be in color yeah
they were kind of pinkish red with
circles and stuff on them and they
didn't they didn't look that good
some stuff is just creepier and black
boy I kind of feel like and this one
because it because of the Arctic setting
I don't think you need it to be like
super colorful you know what I'm saying
yeah so uh so yeah the thing about this
like I said
um it's based on a it's I guess it's a
novella right by John W Campbell who
goes there right yeah it's called who
goes there and that actually came out in
1938 which is crazy I think it was first
published in um astounding science
fiction like the magazine I don't know
if it was all published in one go or if
it was kind of like in pieces what's up
Tammy hey Tammy hey everybody hey Hugo
everybody's here
um and that original story which I read
a very very long time ago
but
um pretty much everything from the John
Carpenter version was in the original
story in the original story uh the alien
did come there and could absorb you know
the physical and mental attributes of
everybody like it that it took over
um one thing that they didn't put in the
movie though was I think in the story
that the alien was telepathic also which
would have made him even more powerful
but maybe I don't know maybe they
thought well that's just going like one
step too far and it's getting a little
new agey or whatever so they didn't like
want to do that I don't know
so in the carpenter version yeah oh yeah
well that's what I'm saying it would
have been too unbeatable that yeah
that's what I'm saying like it would
just be too powerful you wouldn't be
able to fight it because it would know
when you were what you were thinking
about doing to it chuckleheads like
McCready and his boy would have never
been able to [ __ ] beat the thing
that's true McCready wasn't the rocket
scientist right okay I wouldn't go back
a rocket surgeon yeah go back and go
back and watch Carpenter's versions he's
doing a lot of [ __ ] that you shouldn't
done like he's blowing him up with
dynamite yeah dumb I mean he didn't know
you know what I mean it's like
everywhere they were just desperate yeah
he's spreading those little particles
everywhere yeah doing that neoparticles
yeah each one of them was alive yeah
explosions don't kill things the way a
lot and Destroy things the way a lot of
people think it just moves them you know
so you're making it worse just moves it
over there yeah it just moves it yeah
yeah if you see a building blown up it's
because it moved yeah you moved it it
broke into pieces you know it's pushing
it so you know pushing it fast yeah and
uh that's that's all you'd be doing with
the thing you're spreading it around if
you're blowing it up with dynamite yeah
I guess they didn't really know so it's
like they're kind of like blowing it up
I'm like now you're just making a little
a bunch of little bitty anything and
you're sprinting yeah that are gonna
like go all over the place right it's
like a you know like an injection fire
was a lot better idea yeah which they
also used in the 1951 yeah but uh so
yeah so this version uh very famously
directed by uh Christian nibe allegedly
um even though most people I don't even
know if most people say it was actually
directed by Howard Hawks uh who was a
lot more famous he had a producer credit
on it but a lot of people said oh
Christian Nabi you know this would have
been his first directorial credit
because he was an editor and so Howard
Hawks like let him have the directorial
credit even though Howard Hawks as far
as I know like kept almost all the
director's fee which was like fifty
thousand dollars
um I think he only gave Christian and I
be like five grand or something like
that like out of that but there's kind
of like
um the the cast like the way they talk
about it some of them said yeah Howard
Hawks was actually the director or some
have said no Christian nibey was the
director but he deferred to Howard Hawks
because he worked with him all the time
because like I said that was his editor
Howard Hawks
um you know if you don't know who that
is he's very like famous uh you know
Barry golden age of Hollywood this was
the first science fiction film that he
had ever done he did a lot of stuff in
other genres he did a lot of Noir I did
a lot of comedies westerns like he did
Red River and stuff like that and he has
a very particular style which was very
unusual for the 50s and you can see it a
lot in this movie too with all the
naturalistic like overlapping dialogue
it's almost like in modern era it's more
like like a Robert Altman kind of movie
where
you know there'll be like several
conversations going on at once
everyone's talking over each other and
interrupting each other he's trying to
get it to sound more like a naturalistic
you know like naturalistic interactions
and like I said you didn't really get
that much in the 1950s but this actually
really does have that kind of Howard
Hawks you know vibe to it where
everyone's talking over each other and
this you know the dialogue is like
really witty and snappy and funny kind
of you know what I mean so it has that
kind of thing going on which is why a
lot of people thought that uh you know
Howard Hawks had directed it now as I
said uh the novel
Novella I guess that this was based on
did have the alien that absorbed people
and like took them over and replicated
them perfectly so that was definitely
like a thing that was in the original
story but obviously this didn't have a
huge huge budget
so basically what they decided to do was
take all the stuff about like the Arctic
and like finding the spacecraft and
everything but the alien they decided to
make it more like he's like a dude but
he's like plant-based yeah he's like an
impossible alien like an impossible
Whopper but a person yeah he's kind of
like a Frankenstein monster like he kind
of because well and you know who that is
that's James Arness from Gunsmoke
um it's actually I think this was
pre-gun Smoke yeah I'm pretty sure like
this was I don't think this was his
first film but it was like among his
first films and they put so much like
makeup and [ __ ] on him that it's like
you could barely because he was a big
dude you know what I mean they wanted
somebody that was real big and uh the
makeup didn't really look that great
like in close-ups so they kind of like
kept him in Shadow most of the time or
like you know cut out some stuff that he
was in now look I gotta say this
my dad told me the whole vegetable angle
because I remember him telling me about
the original movie after I had seen The
Carpenter's version when I was 13. he
liked the vegetable angle back in the
50s that was good enough back then yeah
it doesn't hold up that the whole
vegetable angle
it's not that creative not by today's
stand and it's very pseudosciency like
the way they explain it they're like oh
it's not that weird there's plants on
Earth that are sentient I'm like are
there are you really yeah I never heard
him be talking about I'm not a botanist
or anything talking about L Ron Hubbard
because he's trying to [ __ ] give him
[ __ ] auditing and [ __ ] trying to
audit the tomatoes yeah do tomatoes
scream when you yeah he's full of [ __ ]
so no it doesn't the the plant angle
does not hold up as being interesting
and it's kind of weird because the
original novel or the short story has an
interesting premise it absorbs you yeah
that's a lot better terrifying that's a
lot better
so you could you could pull this story
off in the pages of a novella but they
weren't ready to do it on screen yet
although I think they could have done it
it's like I'm not really sure if they
just didn't do it because they thought
that it would be easier to make it more
like just a straight up like a
Frankenstein type monster movie or if
they thought that it would be too scary
like I've heard both things you know
what I mean maybe it was like a little
bit of column a little column and B
maybe they'd have thought that had been
like way too terrifying like something
that I think they should have gone for
it but see that's the thing it's like in
a way that might have been a lot easier
because you wouldn't have to you didn't
have to make it like a John Carpenter
like [ __ ] you know special effects
extravagant yeah not show it you could
just not show it because it doesn't have
a form right of its own and then like
but you could ramp up the paranoia like
paranoia like we don't know like which
is like they did in the later ones you
could have it where dude opens the door
and there's some pushing on the door and
tentacles and [ __ ] and then he goes it's
in there it's absorbing that man you
know what I mean it's all you needed
back then to go what it's absorbing that
man yeah you open it up and and and
there's dudes in there and and you know
and the place is torn up and they're all
like what where it's fine yeah then
you're like no you were being absorbed
you know no yeah it wasn't me yeah so
you know I don't know they could have
done it that way I think it would have
been a better it might have been cheaper
actually because you wouldn't have had
like all the makeup on the now that you
mentioned it yeah I think it would have
been a better movie
um but this is the route that they took
it's not a bad movie it's just very 50s
and it was it was good enough to do very
well in the 50s this was massively
influential yeah and honestly this came
out this came out the same year as
um [ __ ] I want to say was it when Worlds
Collide or there was like three real big
it was this one and then like two other
ones that were like really big that came
out that were really really influential
and then that kind of like blew the
doors off like after that because this
was 51 this was early 50s yeah so this
was like really really
influential like a very influential
science fiction film like one of the
first big ones yeah my dad said it was
like a blockbuster everybody loved it
yeah it was yeah yeah and like I said
that it really kind of like it wasn't
just this one but there was a couple
other ones that came out around the same
yeah and they all thought The Day the
Earth Stood Still yeah yeah
he loved Day the Earth Stood Still also
and back back in the 50s like in my
dad's time
these were like Alien aliens predator
[ __ ] you know John Carpenter's The
Thing it's like all that [ __ ] okay it's
on that level you see it now it's not as
impressive as it was but you gotta watch
the movie in the context of the time
right you know yeah I mean think about
how many years have gone by since then
yeah and the thing about it is you're
always gonna like be more scared or more
affected by stuff that you saw when you
were very young yeah um and it's gonna
seem like much scarier to you like you
know if kids nowadays like see something
from the 1950s that's obviously not
going to be scary to them if you if you
like Carpenter's version you watch this
movie you see where a lot of carpenter
got his ideas from yeah yeah some of the
scenes in here like they they took it
like he was homaging yeah there's
there's a character in here named Mac
yeah although I think he's he's
McPherson actually McCready they just
call him Matt he's McPherson I don't
know if they ever call him he's kind of
just a bit part but uh and also just the
Interiors the way things look you can
see where Carpenter got it the interior
of the camp
and he does not make certain mistakes
that this movie makes and I can I can
tell that he sidestepped that [ __ ] on
purpose like the whole close the door
thing it's obvious that that dude is not
in a cold environment that that house is
not in a cold environment they have to
keep telling you it's cold to make you
think it but that house is fun is like a
mock-up of a house somewhere in Southern
California in the 50s it is yeah it's a
it was on a Sound Stage although I will
uh I will give the movie credit a lot of
the exteriors like with the snow and
everything like that were shot yeah they
look good in uh Glacier National Park in
Montana and they look good yeah so
Carpenter learned from that
[ __ ]
so I think I think Carpenter was like
I'm not going to make that mistake and
I'm going to do what they did there so I
like I I I the movie is very instructive
okay I can see what Carpenter was doing
when I watched this movie
yeah the Interiors are great the
interior of the camp
that's straight out of John Carpenter's
version yeah he made it look like pretty
much like yeah and it's realistic it
looks pretty realistic even the 50s
version
Sasha Fred said I noticed this as well
it said I noticed in the 80s film all
the characters are male and in the 50s
film there is a female character because
the 80s film was more realistic yeah I
kind of feel like the 50s one they just
feel like you know and and I really
actually really like the female
character in this she's actually one of
the best uh care and she actually wasn't
um this was kind of her only major
acting role she was more like a model
and I think she was like great in this
she's like really funny and like really
you know she's very personable
um I think that she's in there she's
like a secretary to the doctor right and
she's the doctor secretary so that's why
she's there but I have to have a woman
well they have to put her in there
because there's always like a romance
had to be like shoehorned in there
because like the main dude you know was
like now that I will say though that
that does lead to like some funny scenes
the one scene where because I guess
um her and that one dude
um they they had like a prior fling or
whatever and so he's trying to like
rekindle that flame right and she's like
just teasing him about like how handsy
he was like he was an octopus or
whatever and then like later on she
actually like ties him to a chair and
she's like like putting Like Liquor I
was like oh okay this is pretty dirty
for like 1951.
I was like got some BDSM actually going
on there it wasn't that but it's like
that's what I thought of now when I'm
talking about the realism I know because
I was stationed at a place called op311
which is a desert island right outside
the Gulf of Aqaba outside on the coast
of Egypt or Sinai Peninsula and it's
it's the desert version of [ __ ]
this uh Antarctic or north North Pole or
Camp our camp was about one-third that
side that size but all the same stuff
you got generator men and [ __ ] burners
and cooks and Medics and
and in a situation like that it's a
military slash government backed
situation especially in this era there
wouldn't be a woman for a hundred miles
it's just military guys and government
contractors
and in in Carpenter's version these are
those are government contractors
ex-military government contractors in
that weather station
and a lot you know McCready being a
Vietnam veteran helicopter pilot and the
other guys you know they're merchant
marines and ex Naval guy you know
because like that one dude's got a damn
earring one of the Medics guys he's got
an earring that was Merchant Marines
back in those days so Naval guys manned
those kind of posts no women would ever
want to be down there man there's
nothing to do nothing
those are desperate men that have no
incomes and they have a [ __ ]
uh uh uh their worksheet [ __ ] allows
it these are the same guys that work on
them
offshore oil rigs it's that same kind of
guy and uh which is those are tough
[ __ ] you know what I mean but
that's not select stuff you know what I
mean you make a lot of money but there
are no social life at all brutal it's
like being a long-haul trucker worse
worse than that so that's a great
setting for a story like this great
setting because it would because crazy
[ __ ] would happen in a place like that
it wouldn't it wouldn't happen at your
local drugstore or grocery store it'd be
in some weird place where there there
aren't normal people it's on the edge of
civilization so that's why this movie is
cool
yeah they're up on the North Pole in
this version not not the Antarctic but
the North Pole yeah this is Arctic they
start out in Alaska and then they go up
to like they go up to the circle because
they're investigating what they think is
a plane crash now that's another thing
yeah I think it's kind of this is kind
of odd this version yeah
aren't they implying that the that the
spacecraft crashed not too long ago yeah
and then in the same story they say it's
millions of years old
that's what I'm like wait a minute hold
on I thought I missed something well
because the thing about it is that the
John Carpenter version your legible is
like the like the spacecraft didn't just
crash a long time ago yeah for like a
really long time because this one there
they that's how they knew to go out
there and like look for it because it's
like oh we saw some weird [ __ ] they
thought it was like a weird plane that
had crashed so they went up there to
like invest in the carpenter version the
geologists or the isologist I don't know
what it was because this ice here man
has been this is at least a hundred
thousand years old you know so that that
craft had been there for uh at least a
hundred thousand years
which that's plausible right see that to
me that like I know that's weird but it
kind of makes it like a little bit more
blue because not only with this thing
when you're dealing with [ __ ] alien
spacecraft and [ __ ] like that
probability has a lot to do with time
and space chances are this is something
that happened a long time ago a long
time ago something crashed here and it's
still alive
that's far more likely than you're just
walking around hey look we saw something
crash that's extremely unlikely when
you're dealing with so much space and
time in the universe
that's what I'm saying I think that's
what made like the carpenter version
like more believable in that sense yeah
Carpenter's pulling you in and you're
like this is a documentary because
that's been there for like a really long
time yeah and they blew it up and they
blew and they got the whole I always get
blew it up in this and you realize
I mean it blew it up
it was kind of like hilarious this is
kind of hilarious because it's like they
they find out where the [ __ ] is like you
can see it from the top there's like an
ice and it's kind of like round and
stuff and they're like okay well that's
where it was so they go get in their
helicopter or whatever and they go out
there and get it and then they couldn't
afford to show it I guess like the the
spacecraft
so they just had the scientists and
actually like a really cool like iconic
scene it was very stylized and I like
the way they did it but they had all the
scientists or all the guys like standing
around in a circle like stand on the
edge where you see like through the ice
and so that's like this big circle
they're like oh my God it's a flying
saucer that's awesome and then that one
guy that's like the reporter who keeps
saying holy cats all the time like he
says that all the time so so they're
standing there like that and they're
like well we have to get it out of the
ice so let's put some like thermite
bombs yeah we're gonna be in there and
they I mean they didn't mean to blow it
up but I'm like well obviously and then
they're like oh [ __ ] we blew it up right
I'm like what did you think it just
wasn't shipped off the hook hey if the
ship gets destroyed from the thermite
don't worry oh we're off the
in The Carpenter's version [ __ ] you got
McCready going and the dumb
[ __ ] blew it up
and and referring to this probably yeah
you refer to this movie Dumb
[ __ ] they blew it up and then
Carpenters blaming it on the Norwegians
I mean Americans aren't so dumb that
they blow it up that no regions did that
[ __ ] it's a great it's like like a
carpenter working his magic I know it's
like that that was like so funny to me
because I'm like in this movie I'm like
like I said I know that they were doing
a work around because it's like what we
can't afford to build like a big
life-size alien spacecraft yeah so let's
just say like oh they can kind of see it
through the ice and they're like oh
we're gonna try and get it out of the
ice with thermite bombs oh [ __ ] we blew
it up and I was just like really okay
Carpenter solved the issue with it with
the matte painting an excellent Matt
shot right of the of the craft now
here's another problem with this
narrative yeah having military extensive
infantry military experience thermite
does not explode it just burns yeah so
it wouldn't it wouldn't blow it up but
most people wouldn't have known it just
sit there and just burns like a welding
Arc we use it to demolish captured
equipment if you capture a vehicle and
you can't take it well I think they said
on the engine and [ __ ] burst it I
think they explained in the movie if I'm
not mistaken that that's what they
expected it to do but out of the ice to
melt it out of the ice but then it
reacted with some weird metal yeah
because that made it blue blow up so I
think they did actually explain that
yeah I think if I remember correct
thermite does not explode right yeah
that's why they didn't mean to blow it
up if I remember correctly it's about a
50 50 mixture of powdered aluminum and
powdered magnesium I think that's
basically thermite
it just
goes off like you know sparklers like
that on steroids
Danny Rowling said does the monster in
this film talk no no thankfully no and
he doesn't listen for very long either
he's like I don't know your [ __ ]
knocks his ass away yeah yeah I mean
basically like I said he looks like a
dude obviously it's James Arness uh in a
big like a jumpsuit but with some weird
[ __ ] on his head and he has like um it's
just like spikes like on his the Thorns
like Authority hands because he's
supposed to be like a plant guy which
like I said I guess in the 50s they
could have made him look like you know
Swamp Thing or something like that
that'd have been neat but um they did
it's basically just like a guy with some
weird [ __ ] on his head but they don't
show him all that much I think you get
like 40 50 minutes into the movie before
they even show him like it's mostly kind
of like people talking about because
like I said it was pretty low budget so
it's like it's usually people coming in
and being like Oh my God it's like some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] was like happening in the
other room you know what I mean but they
don't like show it ever he's just in a
flight suit pretty much yeah and he does
the kind of things that Frankenstein
would do he's a little more athletic but
not much just a threatening big
[ __ ] with horny hands you know
the dude's got horny hands and uh
everybody's got a horny yeah right I
don't know why Frankenstein kind of head
on the top of it yeah he's got a
frankenheit and um he's an alien and
he's here to whip your ass he's not here
to [ __ ] talk well he's he's here to
drift off blood to chew gum and drink
blood yeah and kick ass yeah I mean it's
just like McQueen just like McCready
from the carpenter version I don't know
maybe he's just been frozen in the ice
he's pissed off I don't know why that's
pissed off too yeah it's frozen and
that's kind of like it's kind of like
Crustle and [ __ ] McCready into the
second one is just explaining what
happened in the first one I don't know
he's just pissed off yeah because that's
really
the essentially essentially that's what
happened in this movie doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense well he's kind
of trying to stop he's trying to
propagate himself yeah he's been frozen
in the ice he drinks blood yeah and then
well because look like the scientist who
is kind of the antagonist or at least
like the secondary antagonist and it's
like the alien is the bad guy obviously
but the scientist who wants to keep him
alive he doesn't want to destroy him who
wants to study him is also kind of a bad
guy so this is like kind of like a
little bit I don't know if I'd go so far
to say it's like an anti-science movie
but the scientist in this is like
essentially like the secondary bad guy
yeah because what he wants to do is he
is taking because what happens is like
the alien
he goes out and like he fights with the
sled dogs and he and he kills one of the
sled dogs and like drinks all the blood
but during the fight like he gets his
arm ripped off and then the um well yeah
that's what that's one thing is like
he's kind of like a plant person so like
his chick or is back like if it comes
off but also like the scientist takes
the severed arm and then he starts
taking like blood from their blood
supply like that they're supposed to be
saving in case anybody gets hurt like up
there on the thing but you know and it
starts feeding it to the seeds I guess
like kind of seeds that he found in the
arm and so he's growing like these
little plants so he's like cultivating
like little alien baby plants just just
to see what would what will happen
because you know he's a scientist he's
like we have to know we can't destroy it
whereas everybody else like are all like
the military guys and everything else
like we have to [ __ ] destroy it it's
gonna take over the [ __ ] world and
you know what I mean and then the
scientist is like no you can't Nick Nick
seen the uh remake the carpenter remake
and not this one no you should see this
one I mean it's it's interesting to see
it's interesting to see where where
Carpenter got a lot of his ideas and how
he Carpenter addresses this movie
in the thing he kind of like
like I don't know he's just pissed off
you know you when you see when when you
know the second when you know
Carpenter's remake well
you can see that he really studied this
movie yeah okay well he loved this he
loved it and though somebody mentioned
the 2011 is a prequel of what happened
at the Norwegian the Norwegians yeah and
I like that movie I did as well I know
Blu-ray it's kind of like half people
like it half people not so much I liked
it too I like it um
it was gonna be an homage to carpenters
and have all practical effects and they
did evidently really good practical
effects for it but then the company that
the studio that did that decided in
their wisdom they're like well we want
this to look more like a new movie we're
going to cover those practical effects
with CG
which evidently pissed a lot of people
off that the Practical effects
underneath that CG was super good well
most people that are into horror movies
like that it's like yeah let us see the
Practical if I would I would rather see
a slightly substandard practical effects
yeah then okay looking yeah now in that
movie's defense
you're going to call it a CG movie now
or like CGI but it's some of the best
CGI because you the actors are reacting
to something that's really there yeah
because when they shot it it was there
because when they shot it it was there
right they were reacting to a practical
effect and that they cg'd over it uh
which
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna let's say
that that they canceled each other out
I'm gonna say it's a good movie I liked
it and it was in the spirit of
Carpenters very much so
um
it's hard to top an original okay it
just is
does it top the original
in some ways it shows you more it even
shows you inside the alien spacecraft
and I thought it was a very realistic
depiction because you don't recognize
anything in there
I mean
there's one time where they go to this
Central room and there's just all these
little cubes
appearing and disappearing and making
this weird pattern everybody's like what
the [ __ ] is that
who are you to ask what that is we don't
know what they know what that is they
know what that is you're used to screens
and flat screens and tablets and
whatever this thing is that's their
readout that's their display it makes
sense to the [ __ ] thing okay
which I thought that was a [ __ ] great
touch
it was a truly alien in there you know
it wasn't your opinion of what an alien
craft would be like you would go in
there and you just don't understand it
I love that kind of [ __ ] yeah yeah well
no no see 2011 thing also good we saw
the theater when it came out we did yeah
I liked it I did as well I wasn't
expecting to but it's like yeah I really
like it yeah but the thing about it okay
so can we talk too about the 1951 one
okay the thing
how the thing gets thawed out yeah
yeah can we talk about this for a second
yeah because it's like them blowing up
the spacecraft I'll give them that like
that was an accident okay like I said
they they had the thermite it's like
they were kind of like they didn't think
it was gonna blow up and it reacted with
the metal okay fine
but then they're like okay well we can
salvage this one the pilot you know the
alien in this big block of ice and we're
gonna put it in you know the The Outpost
or whatever and it's like we're just
gonna leave it right here we're gonna
study it like the higher-ups want to see
it or whatever so we're just gonna leave
it in there
so then they have somebody like keeping
a guard over it
one of the guys that's keeping a guard
over it gets creeped out by the sight of
the presumably dead alien like in the
block of ice so he's like I'm just gonna
throw this blanket over this ice block
but like the blanket is an electric
blanket and somebody that was in there
previously had left it plugged in and so
it starts melting the ice and he's just
like sitting there literally two feet
away and does not notice
until
it thaws out enough for the thing to get
up and then he turns around he's like
what
and I was like
I feel like there's other ways that that
could have been done I was watching
something earlier maybe it was Dr
wolfila but he actually pointed out that
he's like it probably would have been
better if the scientist who was already
like the secondary bad guy had like
thawed the the thing out you know what I
mean like he had sabotaged the [ __ ]
somebody's like I don't know how it
happened you know because he wanted to
study it that would have made more sense
than just like some idiot throwing an
electric blanket and not noticing that
it was plugged in and also not noticing
that this huge ice block was melting
like right like literally a couple feet
away from him yeah it's just it's a fit
it's the 50s right and it's like we just
need this to thaw out so it can Rampage
yeah
that didn't fly that did not that that
didn't fly a [ __ ] in the new ones at
all either remember [ __ ] in the 2011
one it showed the block yeah you know
how it originally got out
and uh it didn't there was no thought
involved because they drilled a hole
with it and it it [ __ ] woke up he's
like ow who's drilling it yeah yeah
it drilled a hole right through it and
got a sample and it busted out later on
yeah yeah so see the 2011 prequel that's
good
yeah Danny Rowling said I didn't watch
the 2011 version for the longest time
because I thought it was a remake no
until one day someone said it's a
prequel then I watched it was blown away
and bought it on DVD yeah it's about the
Norwegian team that they referred to in
the first one yeah that's what it's
about in the theater when how they found
the the the the the the saucer blew me
away they were just in that damn snow
cat this crawler and it went downtown oh
my God that freaking yeah the headlights
were shining on it yeah I was like oh
man that's falling down I like that
crevasse or whatever holy [ __ ] that was
that was a harrowing scene wasn't it
yeah I remember that that's one of the
scenes that I remember the most from
that movie because it like [ __ ]
scared me and it explained how that dude
was frozen and cut his [ __ ] throat in
his [ __ ] hands and froze himself and
everything that happened and
um
and in the Norwegian team there was a
female I think there was one yeah it was
just one and they brought her on but she
hadn't been there long they brought her
there she was a biologist if I remember
correctly
and they knew that they had found that
creature and they needed her so it was a
good
2011. actually the 2011 I think there
were two women well because they yeah
because they brought the biologist and I
think there was another woman there who
was a Norwegian woman it was already
there because the biologist was American
but I think they also had a Norwegian
woman but I can't believe I can't
remember like what um like what her job
was yeah but the thing about it was like
even in the John Carpenter version I'm
not super clear on what all those dudes
jobs are
like I know like what like Windows he
was the communications guy right right
yeah um the guy on the roller skates was
he was the hook he was the cook yeah
right that was Child's right no no that
wasn't child's uh it was shot um child's
was Keith David yeah I forgot what the
other guy
the other ones were generator
you had the dog guy and then Wilford
Brimley was the doctor he's a like
medical like medical and then there was
weather scientists yeah there you go
McCready was the pilot
you had a head of security the guy that
had who was Ram from [ __ ] what you
call it that's right he's had a security
so he was from Logan through on TV
Logan's right I got a comment on that
the other day because remember we did
that Logan's Run TVs like a long time
ago yeah I just got a comment on there
yesterday that said thank you so much
for not like uh tearing this one a new
[ __ ] like most people do because I
guess a lot of people like negatively
review it and somebody came on they were
happy that we hadn't done that I'm like
I liked that series seriously I didn't
think it was bad well it had problems uh
the aliens well sure but you know it was
the of its time yeah of his time I'm
willing to like watch things in the
context of their time and I'm willing to
give a lot of [ __ ] a break like if I
know that it didn't have a lot of like a
high budget or and I can tell what they
were trying to do like I'm I'm I'll give
it a lot of leeway you know what I mean
yeah Nick says I saw an old movie the
other night that blew me away the night
of the demon from 1957. I've been
wanting to like um review that for like
a really long time because I really like
that movie uh I highly recommend it if
you haven't seen it really creepy yeah
that's a really really great [ __ ] 50s
movie we should probably review that one
of these days I've been wanting to do it
for years I haven't seen it since for a
really long time yeah it's a [ __ ]
classic it's really really good
um yeah so I do kind of feel like if you
like the John Carpenter one then it's
really interesting to watch this that's
why we wanted to watch this one I saw
this movie when I was a kid but I didn't
really remember that much about it other
than oh I forgot to mention too I think
the best scene in this honestly is when
the thing like the alien like busts into
the room and then they throw kerosene on
it and set it on fire like set him on
fire with this with the flare gun or
whatever good stunt
um that I think was either the first or
one of the very first like full body
burn stunts ever and it's looks really
good I mean I was watching it I was like
wow that could have gone horribly
horribly dangerous very deep they were
throwing flammable [ __ ] fluid
everywhere because he was already on
fire and they kept throwing kerosene on
him and I'm like holy crap that poor
[ __ ] stunt man yeah that could have
gone like really really wrong it looks
fantastic though like even today I think
from another world was a great movie in
its day it's not a bad film of today but
one of the things that it does it's not
a bad film by today's standards but what
really what it's best
suited for
really is a supplementary kind of
it supplements um John Carpenter's The
Thing it shows you what it was he was
trying to fix
okay yeah because yeah and that's maybe
a good way because Carpenter's version
was closer to this to the short story it
was yeah so he was restoring it it's not
a remake it's it's another adaptation
yeah it's more kind of like a repair
it's like yeah that that thing the old
thing was good but it's so different
from the book let's fix it that's what
he's doing
and he took all the strong points from
this movie and included it in his got
rid of all the weak stuff and then
restored the story even though he told
it his own way there's a lot of stuff
that didn't
from the book I think the names of the
characters are all different the
morality Tales aren't there there was a
bunch of morality tales in the first one
I think about greed corporate greed and
it was uh it's been a long time I've I
read an animated version of who of who
goes there and it's it's a lot different
than the thing but it's the same general
concept it's the same general story yeah
uh dudes being absorbed by an alien
creature and they don't know who's who
anymore because like every like people
can't trust anybody right which like I
said I kind of feel like the you know
the the Howard Hawks 1951 version it
kind of doesn't have that
paranoia aspects it has a little bit of
that I guess but it doesn't have it to
the same extent that the John Carpenter
one was did and like that also the
original story had because it's like you
don't know like if you know suddenly
your best friend or your spouse or
whatever it's like they could be an
alien now and they've been absorbed and
you don't know because they look and act
completely the same yeah like to me
that's way way scarier yeah than just
like a lumbering monster that you can
like throw fire at you know and that
they electrocute at the end Carpenter's
version becomes basically [ __ ]
Kurt Russell and Keith David all right
trying to figure out who's the thing all
right it's just a [ __ ] classic and
they're using what a great [ __ ]
ending yeah that is a great [ __ ] it's
one of the best endings they both live
and I both think they're not the thing
I think they're not the thing but they
both die okay
um I mean one or the other could be the
thing neither one could be that I think
they could both be the thing but the
thing is though is they show Keith David
and he turns his [ __ ] head and he's
got an earring in
so and when you got an earring in you're
not the thing yeah they've established
that because he can't um yeah they can't
replicate like an organic material right
he got it so like fillings and stuff
right yeah well that's the thing you
can't you kind of spoiled the 2011
version because there's other ways to
figure out right who's the thing okay
and they were using another way okay in
2011 they hadn't thought of the blood
test didn't have time
and it's things like do you have
earrings that kind of [ __ ] yeah there's
other ways yeah because that comes up to
you yeah because that comes up too so I
really recommend a 2011 prequel it
I can go back to it anytime I enjoy it
every time I watch it so it stands up it
really does like I said you're never
gonna top the John Carpenter one I mean
to be honest that's one of the best
horror movies of all time yeah honestly
that is even even the weaknesses it has
it's still good because it's in my top
five I mean sometimes it's number one
sometimes it's number two
um depending on what mood I'm in that
day but it's like it's definitely in my
top five always I mean that film I never
get tired of it and poor carpenter I
think
what happened to his version of the
thing it's got its ass kicked at the box
office
and critically it got terrible reviews
terrible which is like I think the main
criticism of the time was just like oh
it was just like this big yeah it was
just like this big gruesome [ __ ]
stupid like it was over the top and
stuff like that I'm like whoa and E.T
kicked its ass at the box office
at the box office I think I think my
parents even took me to CET when it came
out and the thing was [ __ ]
one of the best movies ever [ __ ] made
I mean it's easily one of the best
movies ever and I think what happened to
that movie I think that kind of [ __ ]
crushed Carpenter
because you never really was quite the
same I mean he did come up with some
good movies after that yeah because
other people recognized I think
important people realize like no that
was a [ __ ] badass flick right because
he kept getting work and he kept making
bigger and bigger budget movies
had E.T not come out that year and had
people not been not so prejudiced
against horror movies
the thing was the best movie that year
easily Blade Runner came out the same
day as the thing do you know that I
didn't realize isn't that crazy oh
that's another I didn't realize that
either that was another weird factoid
that I came that I came across today
while I was going down that rabbit that
movie got [ __ ] raped that movie got
rapes too though it did though yeah it
failed that was another one that didn't
get appreciated until much later like
sometimes that happens and it's like I
can understand how man how [ __ ] uh
that would just like bum you out because
it's like you spent like so much blood
and sweat and tears this is my best
boobie and it's like I love it looks
like it's like it's a labor of love and
then you release it you think it's the
best thing ever and then
like everybody just like poops on it
yeah and I'm just like man that's really
gotta [ __ ] disillusion you I get it I
get it it's not just us and our
generation I've seen reactions to the to
Carpenters the thing with young people
who have never seen it before and it
blows them away they were like that's
the best movie I've ever seen okay yeah
I definitely don't think it's a thing
where it's like oh well you have to go
back to 1982 and you have to like give
it because sometimes like there's two
kinds of movies there's a there's a
movie that you can watch anytime and
it's just Timeless like it doesn't
really matter like even if it has like
some little dated things because
obviously it's going to
um it doesn't matter because it's just
like so [ __ ] awesome that anybody
from any generation can watch it and
just like enjoy it and then there's like
the kind of movies that are good but you
have to kind of cast yourself back into
that into the mindset of when it was
made yeah and to enjoy it the thing is
one of those first kind of movies where
it's like you don't even have to
I don't honestly I don't know like it's
hard for me to say because you know it
came out when I was 10 years old but
it's kind of like I don't think it's
dated at all really it doesn't seem
dated to me
in in most ways well it's practical
effects so that's what I mean that's why
I'm saying that you should always kind
of go with practical effects when you
can because it doesn't date if you do
CGI as many filmmakers in the 90s and
2000s found out to their uh Chagrin
um you know 10 20 30 years later that is
going to look like absolute ass yeah now
there was a um a video game for the
thing yeah somebody mentioned that up
thread I think yeah they mentioned okay
yeah and um I had it I had it on a
laptop for a while but I got Xbox one
now and I don't think it's available for
Xbox one anymore they need to re-release
that and remaster it because uh I
remember [ __ ] liking it on uh on PC
it was real good it had a bunch of
elements where you're talking to people
you don't know if they're the thing or
not and then you have people joining
your party and they have like fear
levels so how scared they are and
whether or not they trust you right it's
pretty cool it's kind of like a shooter
Survival game
pretty neat and then the the thing does
bust out and [ __ ] little pieces of it
[ __ ] run around everywhere and you
got different weapons
yeah it probably doesn't look good by
today's standards but if they need to
re-release that game yeah that would be
fun I don't think they have it for Xbox
one anymore
Nick says Palmer has the best line you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding yeah I love
that they dropping out of the sky I love
that so much because it's like that's
exactly how you would react if you saw
like a severed head come to life and
have spider legs and just like crawling
across I mean you just wouldn't be able
to believe it yeah so it's like that was
like [ __ ] perfect it was like a
perfect [ __ ] reaction
uh Nick also says I was the only kid
that hated E.T at the time I loved the
thing yeah I didn't really like t-e-t
either I I kind of well it was like I
said I I was 10 when I saw it so I was
kind of like oh this is nice but it's
just kind of like when I saw it again
later I was like hey yeah I was like 13
I was like man that's kid [ __ ] yeah yeah
I mean that was I was into the thing and
[ __ ] Blade Runner and then around
this time also [ __ ] Flash Gordon the
movie I [ __ ] love Flash Gordon it
might have been a year after that I'm
not sure but it kind of all kind of
Blends into blurs in together now you
know yeah it was a long time it was a
long time ago uh Richard Brown said have
you seen the void yes I've seen that a
couple of times and it's awesome it's
great uh very lovecraftian
uh slasher Fred said Keith David later
appeared and they live yep that's right
we reviewed they live like a long time
ago got it on Blue wraith great movie
one of the greatest fight scenes of all
times between [ __ ] Keith David and
Rowdy Roddy just trying to over try to
get him to put his sunglasses on so he
could see the Haley you can see that
there's like beating each other up for
like how long is it like six minutes it
might be longer than that actually it's
long it was long on purpose yeah
and it's just like the longer it goes on
the funnier yeah I don't know why that's
so [ __ ] funny to me but it's like I I
get it I get it Keith gets him on he
goes oh I see it now
all that time God damn it it took all
that time just to get it to put the
[ __ ] glasses on it's like [ __ ]
hilarious so is that it uh I think so
like I was trying to think if there's
anything else that I want to say so yeah
so yeah I mean if you like 50 sci-fi you
know if you like Day the Earth Stood
Still if you like that kind of stuff
then you I mean the thing from another
world you kind of have to see it because
it's one of the kind of foundational
um science fiction movies right it's one
of the earliest ones and it's one of the
most influential ones now now that we've
seen like the John Carpenter version
which is kind of like the definitive
version of this story you know you can
see where a lot of the flaws are but I
mean there is still a lot to enjoy in
there but you can tell that it's very
it's very 50s it's very low budget I
still had a good time watching it but I
mean you know the John Carpenter one for
me is like that all day right I mean
yeah from my point of view the purpose
of this movie is to learn you watch this
movie to see what Carpenter did and what
he changed and where he got good things
and and how he avoided
some of the mistakes that this movie
made
it's
it's enjoyable from the point of view if
you're gonna you know if you want like a
50s monster movie yeah it'll give you
that
The Carpenter's version is much better
yeah this is a good supplement to that
I'm gonna agree with that but yeah it is
like a really interesting thing to like
as as two adaptations of the same story
um you know one of them
done with more modern uh techniques and
like with more money and the 50s one but
like I said you can see why the 50s one
was so influential yeah and it's
interesting too because I kind of feel
like in the early 50s because like I
said this was 51 and in the early 50s
you still kind of had a couple different
threads of sci-fi like I said this one
was very
um almost like anti-science you know
what I mean because like the scientist
was the bad guy and it's like the fact
that he wanted to keep the alien alive
like so he could study it whereas like
the restaurant were like [ __ ] that we
just want to like kill it so you know
they it kind of leaned very hard into
that well that's the same as aliens
though right well because I kind of feel
like too but then you have like some
other ones like um some other sci-fi
moves the period that kind of had more
like friendly aliens or aliens that came
there you you know to you know give us
some technology and then and then we
like [ __ ] up and like shot him or
whatever so there's kind of like two
threads going on there so I think it's
kind of interesting in that regard and I
thought it was interesting too just
because of like Howard hawks's
um you know sort of fingerprints on it
with his very classic uh you know
everyone talking over each other his
very like his super Snappy dialogue
everyone kind of making these little
witty asides and like witty remarks and
stuff like that like I did kind of I did
like that so the 50s won as much I don't
want to say it's like funny it's not a
comedy but there is a lot more funny
[ __ ] in it whereas in the 80s one
you know the some of the humor there's
some dry humor in the 80s one but it's
not funny like you know what I mean like
once they figure out what's going on
it's like really really [ __ ] up and
not funny at all and the you know the
80s one is much much scarier
um and it goes back to the original
story of you know being absorbed in like
something taking over your form and like
looking and sounding exactly like you
which to me is a lot scarier like I said
than just like a dude in a flight suit
like with a Franken head kind of
stumbling around and like I said they do
kind of like electrocute him at the end
and somebody said and turn them into a
dwarf yeah they actually did have a
little person actor
I didn't even notice like we were
watching it I thought that he was just
because it's kind of dark like when they
do it and they saw like you know they're
electrocuting him on this what is that
they build like a little it's just a
wooden Walker like a wooden walkway it
didn't have floors they were on the eyes
right that's right so they had wooden
walkways
so it's like so they electrocute him
they get him to walk into this one place
after like after the scientist comes up
and goes you're an alien and like we
could communicate and blah blah blah and
then the aliens like [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
like smack the dude and they're like
okay well electrocute his ass they
electrocute him and I didn't even notice
because it was so dark I thought that
James Arness was just like going down on
his knees or something like that like
going oh I'm about melting or whatever
but apparently there was like actually a
little person actor that they had so
they turned him into what's more and
then like he got [ __ ] killed Richard
Brown said who wins in a fist fight
Keith David or David Keith
I don't know David Keith is uh
um yeah I don't know wait yeah who is
that I know that name but it's like
Keith David had long arms he'd have
reach on you
[Laughter]
all right so um are we ready to like
wrap it up I guess we've been going for
like an hour and I'm like pretty hungry
okay all right so
we'll be back tomorrow evening tomorrow
evening is the main show Tom's very
excited because speaking of aliens we're
doing a UFO show we haven't done like a
UFO sighting show yeah and I got some
exclusive content for this so I was glad
that this uh one and the patreon poll
finally yeah it's about Louis Louis
zamor Lonnie's Lonnie Zamora and his and
his [ __ ] case well guess what when I
was in Korea Lonnie Zamora's son
was my was my squad leader Sergeant so
he knows all kind of like inside yeah
that was I remember what [ __ ]
Sergeant Morris said about this case
it's not and I've never heard it
reproduced anywhere else I can give you
the inside I mean I found some good
rundowns I want to get it good because
this was um this was a UFO setting that
also happened in New Mexico but it's
much much less famous than the Roswell
one although it's still pretty famous
like in UFO circles it happened in 1964
right 1964. and um so we're gonna like
talk about that I first heard about it
on Unsolved Mysteries
um but you know we'll see like I said
I kind of want to get I found a good
write-up in like a UFO magazine and then
I also found a good write-up like in a
skeptical magazine too so we can kind of
like come at it from both angles which I
think will be fun
but uh so yeah so that'll be the show
tomorrow night so hopefully you guys can
join us and I guess have a good rest of
your evening and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow for the main show good
night